Estaba en un lugar llamado Stennis Space Center,
en la costa del Golfo,
y vivíamos en un pequeño pueblo llamado Waveland en Mississippi.
Como pueden ver, una casa muy bonita diseñada para evitar la marejada.
Si se preguntan
qué les pasaría si se enfrentaran a una marejada de 9 metros,
se los mostraré.
La misma casa.
Y allí estoy yo, preguntándome qué voy a hacer ahora.
Cuando digo que perdimos la casa --esto fue después de Katrina--
es porque la casa quizás llegó allá arriba donde están las vías del tren,
o quizás acabó en algún otro sitio allá abajo en el Golfo de México,
y hasta hoy la casa sigue desaparecida.
No sabemos dónde está.
(Risas)
Se perdió.
No les muestro esto para que sientan pena
porque de alguna manera fuimos los más afortunados en la costa del Golfo.
Por una parte teníamos seguro,
y la idea del seguro es probablemente muy importante.
Pero ¿acaso lo que nos pasó aquí va incluso más allá?
Creo que sí porque, como seguramente han escuchado,
a medida que aumentan los niveles del mar,
puede ocurrir algo como esto incluso con tormentas más débiles.
Así que detengámonos por un segundo y veamos esto.
Como saben, el clima es muy complejo,
tiene muchos factores cambiantes,
pero de alguna forma yo diría que todo se debe al agua.
¿Pueden ver esos tres puntos azules en la parte de abajo?
Eso que pueden ver fácilmente, es toda el agua en el planeta.
Esos dos puntos más pequeños, esos son de agua dulce.
Resulta que a medida que el clima va cambiando,
la distribución del agua cambia también de una forma importante.
Ahora tenemos ya sea mucha, o muy poca, y en el lugar y momento equivocado.
Agua salada donde debería ser dulce; líquida donde debería estar congelada;
está húmedo donde debería estar seco;
e incluso la química del océano está cambiando.
Esto afecta la parte de seguridad o la militar de tres maneras:
cambia el medioambiente de los sitios donde operamos,
amenaza nuestras bases militares,
y hay riesgos geoestratégicos, que suena un poco ostentoso
pero ahora les explico a lo que me refiero.
Veamos acá un par de ejemplos.
Comenzaremos con algo que todos sabemos
es una catástrofe política y humanitaria:
Siria.
Pues resulta que el clima fue una de las causas
dentro de una larga lista de eventos.
Comenzó por allá en la década del 70.
Cuando Assad tomó el mando de Siria
decidió que debían ser autosuficientes en cuanto a trigo y cebada.
Ahora, seguro nos imaginaríamos
que alguien en la oficina de Assad le diría:
"Oiga jefe, Ud. sabe que estamos en lo más este del Mediterráneo
por lo que es un poco seco, así que quizás no sea una buena idea".
Pero creo que lo que pasó fue:
"Jefe, Ud. es inteligente, poderoso y atractivo.
Ahora nos ponemos manos a la obra".
Y eso fue lo que hicieron.
Para la década del 90, aunque no lo crean,
se hicieron autosuficientes en alimentos
pero pagaron un precio muy alto.
Lo lograron a costa de sus acuíferos,
a costa de sus aguas superficiales.
También hubo otros problemas no climáticos
que contribuyeron a la situación en Siria.
Hubo la guerra en Irak,
y como pueden ver, según esa línea azul de abajo,
más de un millón de refugiados llegaron a las ciudades.
Y aproximadamente una década atrás
hubo una intensa ola de calor y sequía.
Muchas evidencias muestran
que estaba relacionada con el cambio climático,
causando que otros 750 000 campesinos
se desplacen a esas mismas ciudades.
¿Por qué? Porque no tenían nada.
No tenían nada, solo tierra y arena.
Así que ahora ellos están en las ciudades,
los iraquíes están en las ciudades,
este es Assad, no es que le importe mucho su gente,
y de repente, nos vemos enfrentados a este gran problema
de inestabilidad general
dando pie a que surja el extremismo.
Es por ello que en el ámbito de la seguridad
decimos que el cambio climático es un riesgo que causa inestabilidad.
Acelera la inestabilidad.
Para hacerlo más claro: hace que sitios malos se vuelvan peores.
Ahora, vayamos a otros sitio.
Vayamos a unos 2000 kilómetros de aquí, al norte de Oslo,
a solo unos 965 kilómetros del polo,
esta es, según dicen,
la isla más estratégica de la que nunca han oído hablar.
Es un lugar llamado Svalbard.
Está situada en las vías marítimas
que la flota del norte de Rusia tiene que atravesar para llegar a aguas más cálidas.
También es, gracias a su ubicación geográfica,
un sitio desde donde se puede controlar todos los satélites polares
en cualquier órbita.
Es el sitio más estratégico para controlar el espacio.
El cambio climático ha reducido inmensamente
la capa de hielo que la rodea, aumentando así la actividad humana,
y se está volviendo un sitio de discordia.
La Asamblea Parlamentaria de la OTAN
se reunirá aquí, en Svalbard, el próximo mes.
Los rusos están muy descontentos.
Así que si quieren conseguir un sitio de discordia en el Ártico,
fíjense en Svalbard.
En el ejército
ya sabíamos desde hace décadas, e incluso siglos,
que el mejor tiempo para prepararnos
ya sea para un huracán, un tifón o cambios estratégicos,
es antes de que llegue,
y el almirante Nimitz aquí tenía razón.
Ese es el mejor tiempo para prepararnos.
Afortunadamente, nuestro Secretario de la Defensa,
secretario Mattis, lo sabe bien,
así como entiende que el clima es un riesgo.
Lo ha dicho en sus respuestas escritas al Congreso,
y como él dice: "Como Secretario de Defensa
es mi trabajo manejar estos riesgos".
No solo el ejército estadounidense entiende esto.
Muchos de nuestros amigos y aliados en otras armadas y ejércitos
tienen una visión muy clara sobre los riesgos climáticos.
En el 2014 tuve el honor de presentar en un seminario de medio día
en el Simposio Internacional de Poder Marítimo
frente a unos 70 jefes de armadas acerca de este problema.
Se dice que Winston Churchill dijo,
no estoy seguro si dijo algo pero se dice que dijo,
que siempre se puede contar con que los estadounidenses hagan lo correcto
luego de haber probado todas las otras opciones.
(Risas)
Así que yo diría que aún estamos en el proceso
de probar todas las otras posibles opciones
aunque creo que triunfaremos.
Pero necesito su ayuda.
Esto es lo que les pido.
Lo que les pido no es que saquen su basura reciclable los miércoles
sino que conversen con líderes de negocios,
líderes en tecnología, líderes de gobierno
y les pregunten: "Señora, señor,
¿qué está haciendo Ud. para estabilizar el clima?"
Es así de simple.
Porque cuando haya bastante gente a la que comience a importarle,
los políticos, en su mayoría no tomarán la iniciativa en el asunto,
pero serán obligados,
y las cosas cambiarán.
Porque les digo, al hielo no le importa.
Al hielo no le importa quién está en la Casa Blanca.
No le importa cuál partido controla el Congreso.
No le importa cuál partido controla el parlamento.
Simplemente se derrite.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)